what's up everybody Welcome to candid
truth we're going to talk about the
truth and we're going to get candid with
it I'm excited about today's show
because even though the Olympics are
over we did do a little uh breakdown of
the 2024 Olympics but Aubrey's been
digging deep deep diving into the pagan
origins of the Oly the Olympics in
general not just the 2024 but all
together and we've been looking into
like all kinds of stuff like sports
competition like where did all this
stuff originate from and it's really
interesting stuff I can't wait to get
into this yeah it's a lot so let's just
Dive Right In all right cool let's pull
this
up so what do we have here okay so this
would be the
actual uh Temple I guess Sanctuary that
they would have at the Temple of
Zeus um where the Olympic Games
originally would take
place and I just love love the
illustration because it feels like
you're there sitting in the stands with
everybody yeah um so that's just to
prepare us for what it would feel like
this is I mean it reminds me a lot of
the way the Olympics are today you got
um the stadium filled with thousands of
people you're seeing the Torches I see
all the familiar um imagery and stuff
here
yeah um
so let's begin where it all started it
says the Olympic games like almost all
Greek games were an intrinsic part of a
religious Festival that is something
that a lot of people are missing um I
want us to take note of that tonight
because it is actually
religious ceremony that's why they have
the opening and closing ceremony as well
that should also be a
clue we did talk about that on the uh 24
Olympics you know they call it opening
ceremony closing ceremony and I looked
up what does that word ceremony mean and
it literally means a religious ritual
that's what these ceremonies are yeah
but this is something it's not just like
a conspiracy theory like well it could
mean that or could mean this like this
is Straight From the Source straight
from olympics.com or something right yes
we're going to be reading a lot from
their direct website tonight M um they
actually spell it out for you wow it's
incredible so it's going to be fun um It
also says that they were held in honor
of Zeus so this is also again we'll see
it right away on this Source but um it
was held in honor of Zeus at Olympia by
the city state of Ellis in the
Northwestern pelop panes I probably
butchered that but it's in Greece right
in the sanctuary of the
temple then we see it right there from
olympics.com
it worshiped Zeus Hera Athena and Apollo
wow now we'll get into this a little
deeper but Hara turned into a different
goddess as it went through history and
time down through different
cultures um but it became the Olympic
Games and um so let's just go to the
first link there we're going to start
reading all right bear with us guys
we're pulling this up
okay so I love how this one illustrates
some of this as
well let's go
down all
right okay so right from the horse's
mouth it says as a sacred place used
regularly in religious ceremonies as
well as playing host to the ancient
games Olympia was at the center of GRE
civilization renowned expert Paul Christ
Christen gives olympics.com a unique
insight into Olympia and how the site
changed as the game
grew at its heart the ancient Olympic
Games was a religious Festival held in a
religious Sanctuary whoa this is
straight from olympics.com you can see
it in the toolbar right there
exactly um he's a professor of ancient
Greek history at Dartmouth College
so that should tell you something as
well um he goes on to say it was not
just a matter of playing sports and
Central to this concept was the site
itself Olympia lay on the Northwestern
corner of the peloponese currently in
the western Greek region Zeus King of
the Greek gods was said to have taken up
residence in Olympia around 1200 BC when
the aliens I don't know how to say that
but they
conquered conquered the surrounding area
the Fearsome deity marked his Ascension
by hurling a thunderbolt into the sacred
grove from his home at top Mount
Olympus so this is why we have the
Olympics today yeah
interesting and um the city state of
Ellis the administrative Center of which
was about a day's walk North from
Olympia ran the games through out the
vast majority of its life cycle with
the aliens or aliens seizing full
control from their local Rivals okay so
they're just telling us the history
there um so that is how it came to be
known um during the time it says right
there in bold that they were not using
that Stadium it was filled with wheat
they used it for agricultural purposes
had a threshing floor for wheat um so
then they had to go clean it up let's
skip over that part that was really
quick um here they even
had not just among in the sanctuary
itself but they if we skip to the second
sentence there the sacred Olive Tree of
Zeus from which the victory wreaths were
cut so here you have the wreaths that
were given they were usually the trophy
which sounds hilarious
because have you noticed how much work
goes into the Olympics the athlet into
it when back then in ancient times all
they would get was a laurel wreath or an
olive
wreath yeah that's not much I mean you
get gold medals now well don't get me
wrong they had status I'm sure they had
we're going to read about that blessings
from the gods per se but that's really
what they got physically was just a
wreath wow or a crown around their head
made out of some tree so they're
describing where that came
from um let's see
here the Greeks oh here we go so the
Greeks were aggressively
polytheistic said Christensen meaning
they believe in many gods yes hly Gods
yes so while Olympia is a sanctuary to
Zeus we know that he wasn't the only
deity worshiped at the site there were
over 70 different altars you could
sacrifice to pretty much anyone you
wanted to so let's they're telling you
that there this is all about sacrifices
to Gods this is
religious and yet the stadiums are
filled with people who some even
Christian are participating in this
false god worship yes so that tells you
at least that tells me that originally
this was not a Christian thing to attend
or be a part of and it's not not only is
it Christian there's a lot of secular
things you could say basketball is not
Christian but it is worship to another
God it's yes yeah it's false idol
worship it's not just benign it's not
just uh meaningless entertainment
there's actually it's as a ceremony like
they say we're going to get into that a
lot more because they even have a part
where they tell you they tell you what
they are worshiping here wow um but
because they're polytheistic
we know that Zeus Zeus was not the only
deity worshiped here 70 different altars
okay while the Al Ali aliens I guess
I'll call them maintained a permanent
Presence at Olympia conducting monthly
sacrifices the site turned for one week
per year from an essentially
peaceful Idol into the Mad rius Center
of Greece wow this was actually like
this right here what we're seeing was a
real ceremony
I mean they're they're literally doing
they're not even hiding what this is
anymore well it was actually at one of
the temple ruins as well oh yeah I see
all those pillars and things yeah so
they went exactly to that site and again
we're going to get so much more into
this it usually does have a lot to do
with the sights that they still use
should we play a little bit of this um
no I wasn't really going to use that but
we can go down I think there's more
um anyone who wanted to get a big
audience from all over the Greek World
showed up in Olympia painters artists
orators all went there to put their
Wares on display so here you have the
merchants of the world right
um we know there were total there was
total chaos for a week because anyone
who wanted to raise their profile this
was a place in time to do it h wow raise
their profile so this is like a social
status thing yes if you go here you're
you're seen as being wealthy and
civilized or whatever like cultured I
mean yeah yes and your product whatever
product you are possibly selling or your
artw work whether you're a singer or
painter or something would be put on
display for millions of people that's a
foot traffic yeah interesting so um
let's go down a little bit more I don't
know that most of rest of this was that
important
um oh let's stop there real quick it
says home to practitioners of Wrestling
Boxing pink ration I I don't know what
pink ration is and the long jump the
palestra main feature was a large Square
inner Courtyard it was flanked by
colonades and had an extensive bathing
system in the adjoining rooms okay so
I'm really just discussing the fact that
they had wrestling boxing long jump it
says Javelin and discus throwing yeah
nothing's changed exactly I mean that's
the point people they they think well
that was back then it's different now
there's nothing different they're still
doing all the ceremonial torch lighting
the the opening ceremony closing
ceremony with all these
strange um you know I don't even know
what to call them theatrics yeah really
is
um let's keep going down I think
good all right we're we got through that
one so that is literally just so people
know that's from olympics.com and it's t
slist they're showing you the history
there yes so now there's another site
yes so let's jump to this one this one
was from um if I'm right can you go down
a little
[Music]
bit so here's the first picture here
this was uh when it was in Rio I don't
know what year that was necessarily but
this was hugely
significant because as you'll find out
later even the way that these women are
dressed and what they are symbolizing
has so much to tell
us so let's read through
this um the flame for South America's
first Olympics had been lit at the
birthplace of the ancient games in
Greece starting a 15-week journey
culminating in the August 5th opening
ceremony in Rio de Janeiro so that tells
us
first that when so let me just tell you
a little bit of background where I was
coming from when I was researching this
I looked at the symbolism mhm and you
have this flame why is the flame so
Central to a lot of this right I don't
understand what a flame has will do with
with these games right and then you've
got the
places um the
exact places of worship in the ancient
world where they're actually doing it
again and again right so I went and I
looked up the flame part and I kind of
honed in on that for a while because it
has a lot to tell us so when we look
further at that we will find if we read
next on that page that I'm not going to
pop that bubble for everyone we got to
read it first okay
um that this pilgrimage if you will
let's let's call it a pilgrimage because
it kind of is um started can you go up a
little
bit oh up is the other way um it started
what they call today a torch relay okay
that begins in this particular case 15
weeks
before the actual ceremony even occurs
oh wow okay which was very traditional
in ancient times the torch and the flame
has significance so much so that it made
a pilgrimage of all different kinds of
Runners and ambassadors with it that
would take it from Olympia usually and
bring it all around maybe from Athens or
wherever it might come from wherever it
was being held that year yeah and it
would travel to its site that many weeks
in advance so there's somewhere there's
a flame like perpetually
burning all year or this is only like
every four years and then they bring it
to the Olympics yes and there
if that rings a bell to anyone
like there is an entire worship that
centers around this there's a goddess
there's many things we're going to get
into this
um
so yeah it's kind of strange like why
this it's it's like they're taking this
to a whole new degree of sacredness yes
like guess I mean otherwise you'd just
like oh yeah pour some gas in there
light it on fire but it's like this
sacred flame and even more than that
they change it up every year to get
people's attention and draw crowds but
they had people not just
run but that they've done that in years
past they had people actually they
manufactured a torch that could actually
keep a flame underwater oh wow and I
found a picture from other years past
where they actually had people swim with
it under underwater wow for this relay
and they've had people do it in boats
like we saw we've had all the
this year I didn't watch but I think he
was the one I mean I saw him with a
torch yes so just that's little tidbit
now let's get back to
reading okay
so the games were first held in Olympia
in 776 BC and remained there for 12
centuries that is so true we keep going
back to that nowadays we have it in I
don't know re the Rio we have it in
Tokyo we have it in different locations
all over the world but that flame still
comes from Olympia every year oh my so
no matter where the Olympics are held
they're still the fire from Olympia yeah
wow yeah that sounds like there's some
significance it doesn't sound like
you're just like oh it's just tradition
or something yeah no there's so much to
this so let's unpack it further let's
keep
reading um for the ancient Greek fire
here we go fire was connected to their
gods thought to have been stolen from
Zeus by
Prometheus did I say that right yeah
Prometheus and handed to humans so here
we have a Divine entity or a a gift I
guess given from the gods to humans wow
so it's an ideology we're already
perpetuating here yeah um continuing
on there's some dancing going on
yep um oh looking the dancing though
that really wasn't a huge part of it
they only did that nowadays I guess in
the ceremony but it was to honor Zeus
the fire was lit and kept burning
throughout the ancient games within the
boundaries of Olympia they do this every
year as well once they light that flame
they keep it burning throughout all the
days that it takes oh yeah and someone
is actually put in charge of keeping it
lit multiple people I'm sure but there
just as there are multiple people who do
the torch relay and are the light Bears
yeah the light bear that's what I was
thinking Lucifer the light bear there
are people who once it is lit that are
put in charge of keeping it lit wow and
that again take note of that please put
that in your in your mind on the back
burner because we're going to come back
to that that will be an important thing
to note to honor Zeus I mean they just
WR out say it there's nothing hidden
about this you're literally going going
to the sources and just showing people
what most people don't do most people
just don't research what's the origin of
this what's happening oh it was just
this beautiful ceremony right you're
partaking in a Zeus worship service
ceremony yes yeah so the modern Olympic
flame is ignited at the site where the
Temple of Hestia used to
stand so here we're getting into the
exact goddess which was from what I
understand was Zeus is one of Zeus's
daughters Hestia okay who um again I
need us to get through these particular
sources before we'll actually dive into
that so let's leave that please uh just
put Hestia on the side and we'll come
back to her in ancient Greek religion
Hestia is a virgin goddess of the Hearth
architecture and the right ordering of
domest Domesticity
wow I'm I don't think I'm saying that
right but my tongue is tied Domesticity
that's right yeah okay the family and
the
state
so just I hope you heard that again
we'll come back to it continuing
on this just looks ceremonial and
occultish yes so it says fire was
introduced at the 1928 Summer Olympics
in
Amsterdam we're going to see that it
actually came from from an um I don't
know history like dates that well but I
do know that it came from actually an
earlier
possibly different time anyway that they
used the they initiated that use of the
flame the Olympic
torch so that is going to be very
interesting as well
continuing okay good we're getting down
to the last bits here the torch relay
was introduced eight years later oh here
it's actually admitting it at the 1936
Olympics in
Berlin do we know that Berlin is in
Germany do we know that this was the
time where the Nazis had the Olympics oh
oh yeah I heard about that so I heard I
don't know like I'm not a huge history
buff either but I'd heard that Hitler
got really upset that um an
African-American won against his people
and he said something about how dare you
race an animal against my people or
something yeah yeah yeah was it was very
intense for all the athletes to compete
under German rule right with the Nazis
in front of them um so they have
pictures I will show pictures later I
think um but this is where put this
together M the torch part was initiated
introduced by the Nazis when they first
hosted I guess the the Olympics and
Hitler was a huge ult
he loved all this stuff like anything he
was trying to get the Arc of the
Covenant because he wanted the power he
there was this uh Spear of Destiny that
was on the wall of some building that he
would be inside of and he would just
stare at it and rock and stare at this
Spear of Destiny I think it was Spear of
Destiny I can't um something long ginus
or something but it was supposed to be
the spear that killed
Christ oh supposed to be I don't know
you know these relics that the Catholic
church has I don't believe all of them
are true relics but he desired it so bad
he loved anything just Wicked occult
anything like that and so for him to
bring this flame that was a big part of
the the Zeus worship it doesn't surprise
me
no
so wow yeah that was um it was
surprising to me but I guess it makes
complete sense yeah is surprising
because I've never heard it that but
right yeah it doesn't shock me yeah so
its Journey to the host city has begun
from Olympia ever since there you go I'm
not just saying this they just backed me
up on that that flame comes from Olympia
every year to its host City that's
crazy
okay I I bet there really was dancing
I've always been dancing and worship
like in the Bible days whenever there
was like a well the the Israelites you
know they started dancing around the
golden calf and all that and so here we
have
this ritualistic dancing for
Zeus yes I I mean I don't doubt that
they did but more traditionally it was
not listed as something that was
traditionally done that we know of um
and we've gotten better at theatrics
putting that together with the
ceremonies to make it look more
acceptable instead of very raw like it
back then it was nude and involved
sexual acts and all that and yeah
sacrifices and stuff which we'll see so
11 women representing the Vestal virgins
now they're introducing a
term which is so ancient now that's most
people have not heard of it or it's
going to jog their memory because
it's key to a certain denomination's
foundational uh spiritual practices here
oh wow okay so let's just put that away
again too I'm sorry it has so many
nuggets uh that we have to hold on to
but please just stay to the end you
don't want to miss any of it yes so
representing the Vestal virgins perform
a celebration at the Temple of Hera so
Hera and Hestia actually kind of are the
same goddess they just Chang names in
different cultures and different time
periods which yeah that happens a lot
with Greek and Roman and all that it's
like these same gods are repackaged for
Greek and Rome and then now we have
superheroes and everything so Satan just
loves to repackage false gods right to
fit the
culture
okay so the Vestal virgins were
priestesses I'm so glad they're starting
to address some of this because that
makes my job easier the Vestal virgins
were priestesses of Vesta goddess of the
Hearth again so does that sound like
Hera Hera and Hestia yes it's basically
copycat like I said that changed from
one culture to the next so goddess of
the Hearth and cultivated a sacred fire
that was not allowed to go out they took
a vow of Chastity please make note of
that as wellow of Chastity that's that's
definitely ringing some Bells now yes to
devote themselves to State rituals that
were off limits to male priests H
priests H okay very good let's let's see
what else they have to say the vestals
were a powerful and influential force in
the Roman state so they're being a
little bit mysterious about this Rome
wait a minute Vestal virgins who are
vowed to Chastity in Rome yeah to
priests uhhuh uh
anybody should be picking up on this now
yep um the idea says for the torch relay
was devised by Carl diam who was
Secretary General of the organizing
Committee of the Berlin Olympic Games
what they're not telling you here and
that's a very polite way of
saying that one of
the strategists under
Hitler one of his soldiers of the Nazi
party came up with this idea of the
torch thing yeah right and they're just
packaging it so civil yeah that we don't
even realize that's how they do it mhm
that's how all these holidays and
everything really are you know it's like
oh it's fun it's a tree with decorations
and
it's um carols and CH presents yeah yeah
so
okay the German armaments company
produced the first torch in wood and
metal inspired by an olive leaf so here
you have
commemorating trees tree worship kind of
thing coming in olive leaf Olive Branch
um like we had said before um if you
came in a little late they even had a
sacred Olive Tree what do you call it
Grove there we go
Grove that circled the sanctuary of Zeus
that was used to create these Laurel
well not Laurel I guess then but wreaths
that they would give out as prizes yeah
for for their athleticism and their
great work yeah and
um so anyway they're they're just
worshiping an olive tree and leaf and
everything they're just yeah I mean that
that wreath might not be a big deal to
us but if you worshiped the tree then
that's a huge deal mhm
okay the Olympic flame is lit by a
concave mirror that concentrates the
sun's Rays so don't get me wrong of
course scientifically that is how it
works I get it but the sun is coming
into play here like the power of the sun
exactly why don't they just use a
lighter right yeah yeah which again
would point us back to the fact that sun
worship
yeah Sun worship if you guys didn't see
uh the live stream we did yesterday with
founded Earth Brothers you should check
that out because we did go deep it was
really we were looking through sites
that we saw when we accidentally ended
up in Washington DC but everything in
America and and all around the world
points to Sun worship yeah even these
Olympic
ceremonies yeah
um and
here's wow I'll just I'll just read it
in in the past a high priestess of the
Temple of hair would light the Flames
using
a
scaia the ancestor of a parabolic mirror
so here they are they're trying to
harness like we said the the sun's Rays
to light a fire
which I'm sorry to say this but I have
to say it now this is what they used to
do in the in Egypt when they played
games m as well it was Sun worship where
they harnessed it brought it down to be
the force of the God on Earth while they
would play games competitive games as
well to the gods wow so as devotion yeah
so these types of games are religious I
mean we saw that on the first page the
olympics.com yeah that this was all part
of a religious ritual but you're just
going to keep seeing it more and more I
mean we've already heard it from the
mouth so yeah now we're just going to be
building the case yeah so of course they
had an actress do this she was
performing the part of high
priestess which these actresses they're
just American Idols I mean these are the
these are the new gods of our world
today I mean we don't worship raw and
Horus and Isis now we literally worship
these Idols that if I could just touch
you I'll never wash this hand again can
I have your autograph can I get a
picture with you right yeah and they
live like Gods on Earth they make more
money than they could ever spend they
don't have to spend their money anywhere
they go right
yeah yeah the fact that they even used
and mimicked the role of a high priest
is is very
interesting so thousands gathered for
the event of of course we know that
including
dignitaries from
Brazil oh there's a dove flying in
uh-huh they even say a white dove was
freed into the air symbolizing Peace So
this brings us into the idea which again
we'll get into that further states that
this was
used oh man I think I'm getting ahead of
myself but this whole thing was about
peace and unity that's all I'm going to
say like a coexist movement kind of for
right now yes okay I'm just thinking of
the Bible verse that says when they say
peace and safety sudden destruction will
come upon them I mean a lot of Bible
verses are coming to my mind about this
stuff um you know the whole competition
winning the gold medal which is about
pride and pride comes before the fall
and you look at what what happened to
Rome why did Rome fall it had a lot to
do with these Sports
and uh these LGBT Lifestyles and all
this stuff that they started get into
very
true okay let's continue Rio's torch was
said to
unite movement Innovation and the warmth
of the Brazilian people so here you go
they're having their own take on it and
say just putting it out there like right
in your face yeah so this is what it's
supposed to symbolize in that particular
year
um it will tour okay here they're
emphasizing the the travel of the flame
again it will tour around Greece for one
week before being handed over to the
organizers of the Rio games for the
official start of the torch relay so it
is nurtured it is taken care of
like a baby
yeah it is like
exactly it's a flame yeah of all
things but it says that Greek World olyp
olymp why can't I read gymnastic gymnast
yeah gymnastics
Champion um I'm not going to try to
pronounce that received the flame as the
first torch Bear for the Rio games torch
Bear
yeah um that's not really significant
but here I want to emphasize this
because you we need to realize this just
like in ancient times again I will just
say it over
again it traveled through all all these
different cities to get there yeah this
flame came from Olympia made its way
with light Bears all along the way
passing it along and then you are
responsible for its remaining lit the
whole time yeah day and night torch
Keepers or whatever yeah and then it's
actually telling you how many cities it
had to make its way through this is also
traditional and it was almost worshiped
as I went through State um cities wow
yeah it's it's an offering to the gods
you can't let it go out yeah so they're
going to tell you why though the Olympic
flame visit 83 cities in South America
including the 26 state capitals the
relay will reach an estimated 90% of
Brazilian Brazil's population and will
cover that many Kil kilometers of the
country by Road and that many kilometers
by air over the North and Midwest
approximately
12,000 torch Bears will carry the torch
for roughly 200 meters each so here it's
like a a job yeah it's did we even
know people don't speak about this like
why why is the fire so important have
you asked yourself that why would they
hire that many people yeah that is a big
task and we just think like oh it's it's
the fun little tradition before the
Olympic starts and well that's they
televise it and everything you had a
great Point why just why not just show
up and pull out a lighter and be like
all right fire yeah why why do they put
so much effort into into this yeah has
to be lit by the sun in
Olympia travel
around however many however far it goes
yep to get to the location yes okay so
very good we've gotten to the end of
that one we can
continue on to the next one I hope
you're finding this interesting though
this should all be
little nuggets that we're going to put
together
here so um Olympic flame begins its
Journey today yes so here they even
record its its
Journey
um
and wow um again it's a in the temple of
Hera in ancient Olympia and the flame
will be lit in accordance with the
ancient ritual using the sun's Rays
captured with the aid of of a concave
mirror wow the president of the Greek
Republic will be
present and they're talking this is the
Same by the way this is the same uh year
that we pulled the pictures
from but everyone is there that should
be like everyone important everyone is
there to be there right and I brought
this one up because
um if you scroll down for me real quick
let me
just yes I just I just wanted to
emphasize again it made it its way
through five continents across five
continents and we'll leave
again wow um it will leave
again I lost my way yeah it'll leave
again on the 4th of June for
Sydney okay where it'll make its way
further and further across then they'll
run the flame and Australia would be the
first stage of a long journey that it
has this is
incredible yeah this is a like this is a
lot yeah to but it's a recap really of
what we were talking about let's just
continue to see if they give us anything
else no that's fine I just love it that
they emphasized what I was saying and
yes this one is amazing yeah this is so
in your face so here we're going to dive
straight into their wonderfully this is
roers this is not a Christian website or
anything they're just showing you the
history yeah yes and so that's a great
Point actually because um I might be
wrong but is Rutter Catholic institution
I'm not sure about that I think they're
just a news source I'm not sure all
right we'll just skip that let's just
see what they have to say they just
really Point by point do a good job here
and bear with me because I know we're
going to go Point by point but it is so
golden for us to understand all this
yeah so an ient Greece sometime in the
4th Century BC every fourth four Springs
a trio of sacred Messengers from Ellis
embark on individual Journeys throughout
Greece with a sacred message so every
four Springs that's still what we do
today it's like every four years yes
okay
exactly so and I'm going to point out
something oh there's a caducus y on a
staff okay the caducus if you didn't
watch last night's show we talked about
it
it's uh the staff of Hermes and it's
he's the guide of the Dead the protector
of liars merchants and thieves and
gamblers a you think about what happens
at the Olympics there's all the stadiums
filled with the elites of the world the
merchants of the world they're gambling
they're you know I'm not going to say
they're liars and thieves but that's
what this staff means protector of liars
and Merchants and thieves yes and they
have note there which is amazing as well
that they they would send these
ambassadors dressed in luxury purple
robes so royalty type of robes your
Elite yeah and the messenger travels
mounted on a mule okay so I'm really
glad they're just they're painting the
picture for you so the ancient Olympic
Games for 12 centuries the sacred games
in Olympia were a spectacle of Blood
Sweat and Glory these ancient contests
held in honor of the Gods captivated
Spectators with displays of strength
endurance and skill today the modern
Olympics carry forward this Legacy
uniting athletes from all over the world
so they're still saying you know today
we still do this yes uh worship to the
gods and everything
yes so Harolds traveled to all major
Greek cities around the Mediterranean to
announce the dates of the games along
with the sacred
truce hostilities were banned during the
periods around the games to ensure safe
passage for those traveling to and from
Olympia this is huge they dictated the
political world oh during that time
yeah um during this period War among
Greek city states is forbidden criminal
trials are suspended and the execution
of capital punishment is prohibited so
just shut down the city because the
Olympics are happening yes get on with
the games are we worshiping something
like oh my yeah
you know this goes back to that whole
bread and circus thing yes like the
government is ISL yeah they always want
to be in control of everything and how
do they keep you in check how do they
keep you from being smart and paying
attention it's all about bread and
circus today we have Hollywood we have
video games we have all these
distractions in our life and bread and
circus was something that was coined a
long time ago about the government was
appeasing the people pacifying the
people with bread food keep them fed so
that they won't be hungry and cause an
uprising and keep them entertained and
distracted so they don't know what's
going on politically they're not paying
attention and back then it was a lot of
these circus acts game like um sporting
events and things like that and today
it's just all the worse cuz yeah I mean
people are pulling out their phones they
can't no one can even sit in a
comfortable silence they have to pull
out a phone and play a game or or scroll
on the Internet or whatever we're
completely
pacified and completely fed I mean you
know we still have welfare and food
stamps and things like that the
government does give food uh I remember
the Biden checks were being passed out
at one point in time and everybody was
happy we got our checks you know the
whole bread and circus thing so yeah and
that just made me think of that when
it's talking about that these you know
criminal trials and everything are
suspended like shut down everything the
games are here but it's all worship to
Zeus yes I want to also emphasize the
last sentence here it says during the
Herald's stay Sumptuous Banquets were
also
held so that it really is this bread and
circus thing of give the people food
give them entertainment to keep them
pacified and content with basically
being controlled that's right easily
controllable okay the dates were
meticulously planned
astronomical calculations ensured that
the third day of the games coincided
with the second moon following the
summer Harvest this meant the games were
typically held between August and
September if the same calculations were
used this year the Olympics would begin
on August 17th and end on August 21st
that's really interesting so they're
using astrology toal calulate the the
time of when these things are held and
the Bible has stuff to say about that
too about um observers of times that's
not talking about like keeping the
Sabbath or something observers of times
is about
astrology uh what's your zodiac and all
those things observing times yeah and so
when they're talking
about calculating this with the the
timing of the Moon and everything this
is all Pagan
yes okay
so oh my yeah were people always naked
when they did these um I this guy's
wearing clothes so apparently they're
not just illustrating it's not just some
style of art where everybody's naked I
mean that guy's wearing clothes um I was
learning
that
um a lot of them did go naked because it
was actually
like favor of the Gods to participate as
an athlete any anyway so you're being
prideful and then it was like strip off
your clothing show your muscles and yeah
I to be honest I think they did have
they didn't get into this by the way I
should have been able to probably pull
up some of this but there
was I think some sexual rituals
associated with um the athletes before
they
began their um Sports and a lot of these
pagan gods there was sexual rituals yeah
so
and so it was kind of like well uh easy
access I think yeah was the idea
wow um so it says once the herald
Departed the city began a frantic search
among its young male athletes with the
aim of selecting the most outstanding to
present represent them at the
prestigious Summer Festival in Olympia
for several months athletes would
dedicate themselves to their training
with an increased passion and discipline
fueled by the hope of being chosen to
represent their
City okay so that's all the training
that they do today you know yes all
these people from all over the world
training here they're turning people
into stars or if we would call them Gods
like demigods basically like you want to
be just like them yeah go ahead you'll
be praised you'll be honored you'll be
worshiped well we we just saw a video
today of um some guy he got to meet like
it was just I think it was unplanned he
just happened to be at the right place
at the right time and this Soccer Star
got out and this guy was like oh man I
love he's on his knees with his hands
like this saying I love you I love you
oh my God I love you and he's like
somebody take a picture somebody take a
picture oh my God I mean it was insane
like people don't get that fired up at
church about we're in the house of the
Lord you guys God's here like we we
should be excited but people see these
Idols these celebrities they're supposed
to be celebrated these Idols that we
call Stars which is
it's a symbol for
angels all these words are right in our
face that these are the gods of the
world the Gods Among Us um of this
culture and like you said this U these
training and everything or like who
wants to be the next God yes yes and um
along those same lines the Vestal
virgins were actually selected
originally it was
16 um young ladies of elite families of
of um what did they call them back
then kind of like centurions in the
Bible oh yeah uh
Roman Elite families and it was said
that you would be given honor and status
you would honor them by dedicating your
life to the Roman
Temple um I don't know how many years
but a lot qu quite a lot of years and
then you would actually get to the point
of
being freed from your vow your vow yeah
um to be able to have a normal life and
a family and get married and everything
so yeah this should be I mean I'm I'm
seeing all the connections here with
Rome and V saly and but they they had
two different things that we don't see
today which again I know I haven't told
you who the Vestal virgins are quite yet
but back then they were dressed like to
the hilt these Vestal virgins were
actually like celebrities that female
celebrities that would have beautiful
hair and they wanted to make sure they
were beautiful so that they would stand
out and they'd make being a Vestal
Virgin attractive to all other young
women so the competition was fierce once
they came around and needed new ones
each
year um or each year I'm sorry the years
that they needed new ones and so
um they would actually be able to get
into Gladiator competitions and sit in
the front row H because their status
makes me think of these like beauty
pageants and stuff I I bet a lot of that
has some dark beginnings too well think
of celebrities getting the like front
row seat to the basketball game right uh
just because they are who they are yep
you always see Jay-Z and Beyonce down
the right there on the court and
everything yeah so they would get that
plus it wasn't just
Gladiator stadiums and competitions they
could have that with it was any sport
yeah and then they also when they were
done with their vowed years of
service they could they were also paid a
handsome amount by the church the church
the church the Roman Church
okay um so we don't see that today we we
don't see these particular individuals
really having that kind of privilege at
games or being paid that kind of money
once they're done with their service
time that's true um again that should be
a clue just a little bit of a clue we're
putting together the dots
and um but anyway let's get back to
this finally the decisive day arrives
and judges reveal the names of the
athletes selected to represent the city
in the upcoming games about two weeks
before the start of the games then
depending on the distance that separates
their City from Olympia a delegation in
including athletes and trainers head
towards Ellis now do they're going to
say Ellis many times where do we have
Ellis today I don't know Ellis yes I
don't know what that is Ellis we have
Ellis Island okay I never heard of it
New York oh okay it's the immigration
point at which many people came by boat
to America wow it's also one of the
areas that we have today the Statue of
Liberty yeah a big torch there as well
yes interesting connection yes um again
we will be getting deeper into that in a
few moments but it says in the last
sentence here this city host of the
games is located not far from the venue
of
Olympia according to the Olympic rules
athletes were required to stay in Ellis
for approximately 6 weeks before the
start of the games during this time they
will undergo rigorous training under the
guidance of their personal trainers as
well as trainers designated by the
Olympic Council these official trainers
will ensure that the selected athletes
are worthy Representatives so we have
that today we have it of course they all
have their trainers oh yeah and these
people would train to the max I mean
they're just like days upon days upon
days training themselves to into the
ground
mhm no different apparently especially
from the picture yeah this guy's getting
whacked over the head by a trainer with
a stick that's crazy um yeah so let's
continue the sacred site of Olympia the
games are held at the site of Olympia
very close to the city of Ellis other
cities in Greece held games but the
ancient Olympics were the most famous
and prestigious so they were because it
was the Zeus was the God of all gods by
the way if you didn't know that he is
he's the God of all gods in the Greek
world that's why Olympia which was his
Palace or his sanctuary and Temple was
chosen as the site among all other gods
and all other
temples so yeah um that's why that so
next we
see that nestled in a verdant Valley
nurtured by the alos and clad cladio
rivers and encircled by Rolling Hills
lie the sacred site of Olympia it was
once home to an array of buildings Grand
temples and various venues dedicated to
the celebration of athletic
competition interesting yeah um while
the current dimensions of the site were
well documented the precise expanse of
ancient Olympia remains elusive due to
the transformative effects of
earthquakes floods and other natural
events over the centuries that is so
true but
wow the fact that they said that it was
dedicated to athletic competition yeah
that
already gives us an insight into a
little bit oh yeah yes it
does all right wait did you read that
part we did you read this part yes I did
okay so the Olympic Festival here we
have it's a festival did you know that
you guys
we already said it had ceremony opening
ceremony and closing ceremony and then
Festival but festivals have certain days
of which you do things on them let's
read about that three days prior to the
Olympics athletes along with the
authorities musicians and coaches March
from Ellis to Olympia then following two
days of intense preparation the five-day
Festival can commence day one
contestants and their families begin the
day with procession
to Altus
for Oaths sacrifices and offerings so
that statue says
Ze statue
yes athletes congregate in front of the
statue and the priest offers a Sacrifice
by they officiate it by doing so oh my
okay yeah um so yeah you know we we can
only speculate but who's to say that
this isn't happening today yeah that
there isn't a sacrifice happening before
the Olympics it'd be interesting to see
if there's like prominent people that
just happen to die um before these
Olympic Games
yeah okay we know there's definitely
sacrifices going on um in the industry
and all that yes yes and none of the
worship of other gods is exempt really
from sacrifices of any kind yeah they're
always included so
um to finish that off it says
participants affirm their Greek Heritage
and adherence to the Olympic rules
before proceeding to the council chamber
for animal sacrifices and loyalty Oaths
to Zeus I want to go ahead and emphasize
here their Greek
Heritage okay now it
says that in a different Source sorry um
that I'm bringing up that it United all
of the Greek gods and all of the
Greek um festivals and Greek people but
they didn't care if any other cultures
or gods were actually included
H so why would we be centering things
around Greek
religion yeah I mean
that's that's the question I have with
all kinds of stuff when we were in DC
there was Roman and Greek gods all in
that place everywhere and it was this is
supposed to be you know people have the
illusion
that America was founded by Christians
yet there was nothing Christian to be
found except the name of Moses other
than that everything was humanistic or a
Greek and Roman god with a statue of
Zeus wait was it Zeus Neptune Neptune
Neptune right
outside right front and center outside
the building of the Library of Congress
that's right so it's like another
foretelling that was all Greek and Roman
M um and now we're seeing Greek and
Roman worship all over the place
like somehow our world is focused on
Greek and Roman helenistic is what we
call them today now which I think a lot
of that is just it's
Babylonian Babylon turned into because
Babylon got conquered right when you
look at think of the Statue of
Nebuchadnezzar the prop dream it was
Babylon Meo Persia Greece Rome so
Babylon just became Greece and Rome so I
want to emphasize something here um they
say and I would I forgot to put this in
there but um I was getting some help
from Chachi PT on this because I wanted
to know how the progr the games the
Olympic Games progressed from Biblical
times
to today mhm and they
said um that it is well known that they
had games like these in Mesopotamia
Babylon Egypt and in Greece yeah so
those are the foundations we're looking
at here none of which we're supposed to
be participating in as a Christian right
or really um those were those were being
a part of names that um the Bible would
consider like the most wicked people
like yes don't be like the Egyptians
don't be like the Babylonians you know
the nians and all these things there
were certain people that the Bible used
as like don't be like these people be
like the Israelites sometimes right when
they were doing the right thing and
really when I was looking at this on
chat TBT I also asked them what kind of
sports that they
played it's all the same ones over and
over again it really doesn't and
jousting and all that stuff mhm wow it
was all the same so even the particular
Sports we're playing are a direct
reflection on the worship of these Gods
throughout
Antiquity like anyway I hope that makes
sense I hope that that kind of uh is
interesting to you as well yeah um so
day two and
four only during the second and fourth
day were the sporting competitions held
with the equestrian race being the first
event of the Olympic Festival H so it
was chariot races we don't have those
today I don't really watch the Olympics
so I wonder um they may have something
similar something equestrian um okay so
in those days it was the hippo the hippo
Drome was the largest monument at the
Olympia site but there was there are no
remains okay it is assumed that the
medieval floods of of the alos river
were responsible for its destruction so
that's what it would have L looked like
for the chariot races though look think
of benur yeah if you haven't seen benur
you should probably go watch it it's
good also the aasis an interesting start
system for the Chariots in the race was
apparently designed to prevent the
Chariots from colliding with each other
right after starting and to allow a
rolling start as they enter the
racetrack at the same time
providing all these things yeah this is
more kind of just the rules of the game
right
yeah so that's pretty cool at least that
they have pictures let's
continue foot races this is how it was
set up let's we don't need to look at
that yeah they're just talking about the
markings and everything there you go
though they're
emphasizing all Runners compete naked
yes oh
my okay
um when athletes made a false start they
were physically punished by the Jud oh
they were physically punished this
punishment was also applied to other
comp uh competitions for any
irregularity committed by the
participants the athletes competed
completely
naked I think that's incredibly amazing
that they're actually admitting that
yeah I want to know why though I wish I
knew a little a little bit more about
that but I'm sure it's part of the
religious aspect of it oh I'm sure I
just wish they'd flesh that out some um
anyway it was up to the judges to award
the prize to the winner based on a
series of well executed movements we
already know that yeah we know that
today
um so final competition of the fourth
day was another foot race this time the
runners wore armor including the helmet
shield and bronze gaves a considerable
weight
okay so was this important these are
just look you can tell that these are
the same same Sports though long jump
foot race Javin the javelin these are
not sports that we just do in high
school I mean these aren't common sports
right it's only something you see at the
Olympics right it's not like you ask
people like oh what kind of sports you
like to play oh I like to play Javelin
every once in a while yeah or or what
yeah long jump I mean these are these
are not normal sports or this the disc
throwing so these are very specific
Sports and we see that they are still
continuing today at the Olympics and
it's for a reason it's wow um just one
thing they were saying just in case
anyone's wondering I thought it was
strange they mention they musicians that
played while The discus was being thrown
and we have all kinds of musicians that
always go like Beyonce or
whoever the big act at the time yeah
yeah okay
wrestling uh more wrestling naked
wrestling okay that would yeah that's
boxing boxing naked
also oh pink graci what is this just for
fun of
it um the discipline was a mix between
boxing wrestling no hand protections
were used it represented the most
violent combat allowing almost all types
of aggression except biting or
attempting to gouge the opponent's eyes
so this would be in my mind like MMA yep
UFC and all that okay yeah it's like
kickboxing basically yep day three oh
this is interesting day three I see a
fire here yes okay this day marked the
main festivity okay so this was the main
event yeah they're saying in other words
which coincided with the full moon and
was linked to religious events and
rituals okay they're admitting it no
official competitions were held although
there were demonstrations of sports for
young people a grand procession took
place inside the Altus culminating at
the altar of Zeus with the sacrifice of
a hundred oxen wow part of the
sacrificed animals was offered to Zeus
and burned in a fire okay this is coming
to me right now but when we see I
believe that it was Paul and this other
guy Barnabas the guys that parted waves
yes but they they were in a certain town
and they were taken as gods they were
mistaken I should say as gods and they
wanted to actually sacrifice oxin to
them that's what it reminds me of yeah
well this is crazy because this is
talking about that that torch that we
light at the Olympics I mean this is
this whole thing is about where did the
Olympics start from and they're showing
this big fire that is an altar to Zeus
where animals are sacrificed to Zeus a
false god yeah and this is what we're
still doing today yeah with the whole
torch thing exactly okay the alter of
Zeus reached a considerable height due
to the accumulated ashes wow of the pyes
over the years so they just kept burning
it and building it oh
my oh with the rest of the sacrificed
meat a great banquet was organized that
fed hundreds of people
wow
wow okay so we
should I've never covered this like live
or in public before but I've done some
research
that basically forgive me if this is new
information but a lot of the meat eating
and banquets and barbecue and so on
started usually with these festivals
these Pagan festivals where they would
do
this and you have Odin they did this for
they have Zeus you have other examp
examples you can go look those up
but this is usually where that
originated yeah I'm thinking right now
you know we don't know where this meat
comes from we don't know if it was
sacrificed to false gods or whatever but
you go to these events and what do they
always have hamburgers hot dogs yeah and
we have no idea what we're consuming
when we're there that's why I'm a
vegetarian we're vegetarian and we're
trying to take care of the Holy Temple
that God gave us we want to be as
healthy and live as long as possible so
that we can keep doing God's work and
you know God originally created herbs of
the field for us to eat and we don't
have to worry about eating those uh
animals that were sacrificed to false
gods
yeah okay so we if we
continue day five oh wow
okay meat being taken it looks like yep
okay on the final day closing ceremonies
were held to honor the Victorious
athletes the awards consisted of Olive
Branch crowns these Olive branches have
been collected by a child wow right with
a golden sickle before the games begin
and place on an altar in the temple of
Hera that's really strange actually yeah
the winning athletes marched in
procession from the temple to Hera of
Hera to the Temple of Zeus along with
several judges there were proclaimed win
winners of their categories before the
imposing statue of Zeus one of the Seven
Wonders of the Ancient World so they
would stand before
them so illustration based on the
description by the historian oh do you
see something though that that resembles
what we had just this year he has in his
hand yes a victory figurine in his right
hand which we saw yeah was Nike yep well
it was that they called him the golden
Voyager yes that descended to a desolate
Earth and had all these demons dancing
around no but it was the um sorry there
was there was that other statue that he
was looking at Nike out and it was a it
had angel wings and it was a decapitated
head yeah yeah okay interesting well I
mean very inter the fact that they even
had Nike at
the this past Olympics just shows that
they're not hiding the false God's
aspect I mean we're g to bring out Nike
and and just show you everybody's
filling that stadium watching
participating in all these strange
rituals which they call opening ceremony
and then they bring out the false god
and everybody's you know cheering and
yeah such a awesome thing well it's not
just that it's in past years bringing
that woman riding on the B goal right oh
yeah and all these things that wasn't
the Olympics but that was uh another
same kind of thing it's a different
Olympics B so um my point is and if you
don't know this by now I hope you're new
here if you are here that's great um if
you're new for the first time but you're
probably going to need to go watch the
other videos I've done on
androgyny and also the one called who's
the Rainman because this will make you
take a trail down to its origins of
these different gods where it really
shows
you it's the same as bail worship so
that's why the bull that's why we have
these symbols that are being brought up
where the women I'm just thinking of
that one year where they did have that
big huge bull yeah and these women were
all kind of taunting it but also um
controlling it yeah and then eventually
getting on their knees and worshiping it
yeah and this is all Sun worship because
even Bale was Sun worship the bull uh
had the sun disc between its horns and
we just see the same thing as
being done all around the world you know
even that was a different type of gaming
event it wasn't the Olympics this is
happening all over the world yeah false
god worship and it's it's getting
mainstream it's becoming mainstream and
normalized and I think
that's that's very prophetic that the
world is just being deceived by all
these false gods and just another if you
are someone who wants to look into it
more these were just one of the types
the Olympics again was showcased because
it was for Zeus and he's the God of all
gods and it was the most holy site um at
Olympia but they had other games too
they had the Pan helenic Games and they
had other names um you can go Google and
it actually tells you what particular
gods of Mythology coming from Zeus that
it worships and what games they they
play like boxing or or discus or
whatever so just if you want to go look
into that you can find other games I
used to play that were kind of similar
it really
did mimic definitely watch who is the
Rainman you're going to find out that
Bale worship is prevalent in our world
today and like she said the dark origins
of androgyny I wouldn't even androgyny
you know that's where you can't tell
something male or female or they're
combination of both but the origins are
crazy this is this is not just some new
trendy like I'm trans thing this is a
religious act that people would do where
they would castrate themselves to to
achieve the highest level of uh Nirvana
and reaching that what you call it like
a monk you know like being becoming like
Enlightenment you were you've ascended
to the highest level of knowledge and
Enlightenment from the gods right it's
crazy check that out guys please do um
so the summer festivals of Olympia held
continuously for
1,169 years from 776 BC to 393 ad came
to an end by order of Roman Emperor
theodus the first after proclaiming the
Edict of thessalonica okay so for a
while there they did they
ceased but then they were instituted
again you know like and we have them
today know it's like God brings a
judgment and it something goes away for
a while then it just comes right back
right yeah a different ruler comes on
the scene and it's like no we're going
straight back to Pagan worship yeah full
swing it's going to be here we're going
to make it a national holiday by the way
or whatever yeah well like you think
about Nebuchadnezzar Nebuchadnezzar was
a Babylonian King he was not a Christian
at all and when he threw shadat Meshach
and abedo on the fire because they
wouldn't bow down to his
image there was one he saw a fourth one
in that fire like the Son of God in
there and Nebuchadnezzar said everyone
must worship Shadrach Meshach and Abo's
God he's the real God and he became a
Believer even though he was kind of
overzealous by saying everyone must
worship God never agrees with forced
Worship in any kind of way even to him
God wants freedom of choice but
Nebuchadnezzar became a Believer and uh
over time Pride came back in his heart
and he was on top of the walls of
Babylon he said is this not the great
City that I've have made Babylon you
know and he's getting prideful and he
became like an animal for seven years
because God was humbling his heart he
had to bring him to that point it was
actually an act of Mercy on God to do
that to Nebuchadnezzar because he
probably would have died an arrogant
prideful Pagan King again but after
seven years of this um I don't know if
it's really documented but it's believed
that he did become humble again and got
his throne and all that but later down
the years it was Nebuchadnezzar's
grandson was belthazar or Bel shazar I
can't remember I get those mixed up one
of them I think it was Bel shazar yeah
was Nebuchadnezzar's grandson and he was
like you know getting drunk at a party
and said get the golden vessels that
were taken from uh Israel and out of the
or Jerusalem and out of these uh there
were these sacred vessels to God and he
began to drink alcohol out of them and
that's when you see the handwriting on
the wall so what I'm getting at is you
you have these kings that might be they
might surrender to God but then it's
only a matter of time before another
corrupt King comes in and says no let's
let's desecrate the sacred vessels and
bring that back in
mhm
okay
[Music]
um yeah and they say it's because of
they wanted
to shut down any non-Christian
celebrations now I don't know of course
the guy who did this the Roman emperor
that did this but when we usually have
Christian when it comes the scene it is
rebirthed from a Greek and Roman
standpoint from history
as referring to what we have today as
like I said national holidays National
games or International at this point
even churches that are Roman paganism
veiled in Christianity which are
referring to when it says Christian
usually or the church it is the Roman
Catholic Church that is running the show
mother Church yeah so even for
myself I when I have a church I I have
to actually say what church I'm from
it's not that I am just it's my church
or the church or I am a Christian
usually throughout history that term is
being used so loosely underneath your
nose right that it doesn't mean at all
what you think it means yeah and so um I
have to say that every time it comes up
like it just it's not your church quote
unquote
Christian baptized Roman Catholic
Christianity that brought in all these
games it brought in all these holidays
into our life and our culture
Catholicism is literally just Roman
paganism veiled in Christianity that's
why you have all the uh the saint
worship it's really these are false gods
these are Mercury and Venus and all that
just now they're called St Peter and St
Paul and all these things um there so
many of it it comes from
that Jesus said um call no man father
but your father in Heaven and um they
they accused Jesus of blasphemy because
he said he had the power to forgive sins
and yet now we have a man who calls
himself the Holy Father and thinks he
has the power to forgive sins and
proclaims to be the Vicor of Christ none
of this is Christian but yet the world
looks at that as the epitome of
Christianity when you think of Christian
oh you think of the Roman Catholic
church and you think of televangelists
and all these people they're just the
ones that have the biggest platform and
that's the sad part is that the majority
of Christianity
is not even real Christianity yeah it's
not at all
okay so I wonder if this last part is
important a millennium and a half later
the modern Olympic games that we know
now emerged much has changed and new
additions to the format have been added
such as the torch relay however some of
the sports on display today still bear
resemblance to those from thousands of
years ago wow it's true okay wonderful
and then let's get back to
the presentation here
yes
perfect so there with us guys one moment
here
okay all right next slide okay so here's
where we're going to flesh out
completely that Goddess that I was
speaking about and it mentioned Hestia
or
Vesta um hesta from ancient Greece hesta
is one of the Olympian deities in Greek
mythology associated with the Hearth and
domestic life we already heard that from
them right about Vesta her worship dates
back to at least 1,200 to 100 I'm sorry
a thousand BCE during the height of
Greek civilization okay please just take
this picture and
the white
woman all right now we can go to the
next one so now we have as it turns into
Vesta here Vesta comes from the Greeks
for she is the goddess whom they call
Hestia okay there you go the connection
is made right there her power extends
over altars and hearths and therefore
all prayers and all sacrifices end with
this goddess because she is the guardian
of the innermost things that comes from
the theog Greek myth ology website I
have down there let's read in between
the two pictures there's a middle
picture it says representation of the
Roman goddess Vesta deity of the pan
penates uh assimilated to Hestia is the
goddess of the foyer the countryside and
the bread so they're just adding to this
knowledge that it's the same goddess
yeah but she's over several other things
here too it's interesting she has that
serpent on her hand yes very and a gold
and ring I don't know if that uhuh ties
into the Olympic rings or anything right
okay so I would like to just read this
because we're going to see this
connection coming so we're going to read
the very right inscription there it says
the goddess of the Hearth and Home Vesta
was a Roman deity that symbolized faith
family and domestic order often known
simply as mat or mother okay oh okay
uhhuh Vesta was recognized as the p of
Roman
deities wow okay an eternal virgin or
Vesta inspired her priestesses known as
the vestals or Vestal virgins to adhere
to a strict code of celibacy Vesta was
adapted from the Greek deity Hestia with
whom she shared many
characteristics that just I mean that
totally just gave it away right there
did so who well yeah who dots yeah who's
in Rome that's uh Eternal
virgin
supposedly that's Mary yeah not
literally not the Mary from the Bible
but the Mary that the Roman Catholics
uphold so much and I they will say they
don't worship Mary but they worship Mary
I mean there's literally statues that
I've seen Catholics pray before and um
that they call her a Perpetual virgin
yeah we know that Jesus had other
brothers in the Bible yeah Mary was not
a virgin after Jesus was born U she had
more children and uh but this is just
the false idea this is literally proving
that Roman Catholicism is just this
repackaged uh was that from Greece so
they took a Greek god and just said no
that's that's the Virgin Mary yep and so
they have a Greek god
in their sanctuaries and they have no
idea if Mary really looked like that or
anything you know these these images we
have of Mary wearing the blue Veil and
all that I'm sure is nothing but Hestia
yeah that's who it is okay very good
so yes known as mother mother that
mother Mary there you go mother Mary wow
so the Temple of vesto was one of the
ancient Roman's most important buildings
I'm just reiterating a little bit of
this because I want you to see it from
their mouths I'm going to read the why
it was I guess dedicated to the powerful
Roman goddess of the Hearth the temple
conserved the city's sacred flame
symbolic life force of the entire Roman
State have you ever seen the heart
that's inside of the mother Mary's chest
that's on fire yes it's that Perpetual
Burning Flame yes wow a good point yeah
the Sacred Heart they call it yes okay
so and then it says right here Vestal
Virgin the very definition of it in
ancient Rome a virgin consecrated to
Vesta and vowed to chasti sharing the
charge of maintaining the sacred fire
burning on the goddess's altar in
ancient Rome these vessel virgins were
priestesses of Vesta virgin goddesses of
Rome's sacred Hearth and its Flame the
vestals were unlike any public
priesthood we already saw that but again
just think I wanted you to see the
emphasis they're putting on it that they
say it they maintain the flame the
sacred flame this flame this flame flame
flame
okay so
next why did I mention like I said the
Statue of Liberty we're going to find
out so goddesses named for and
representing the concept
Liberty concept Liberty have existed in
many cultures including classical
examples dating from the Roman Empire
and some national symbols such as the
British britania or the Irish Kathleen
I'm not going to read all that the
ancient Roman goddess libertas okay so
they're now they're giving us some some
backstory here right the Roman goddess
an embodiment of Liberty was honored
during the Second Punic War
okay so we have libertas so then we have
a statue in her honor was also raised by
Claudius on the site of Marcus tulus
okay so we can skip that other part the
figure oh I actually do have to read
this part the figure also resembles Soul
inv victus the Roman God of son y we're
going to get to that as well among the
Romans the cap of felt was the emblem of
Liberty so that's the Fran cap here yeah
that we I mean we recently saw because
like we said it was in the episode we
did with the founded Earth Brothers just
yesterday yep you can check that out go
to founded Earth Brothers page click the
live Tab and you'll see we went on there
yesterday showing all the things we saw
in Washington DC and that very frian cap
yep that's what it's called that frian
cap is everywhere it's the little Smurf
hat the hat that the Smurfs where you
saw it everywhere it was on it was
engraved in the walls everywhere yeah
and it has meaning it's it's also on the
Army seal you'll see a like a a a gun
standing with a little bayonet thing and
the hat is on top of it isn't that a
strange thing to see a little red cap I
mean who what military guy wears that
usually there's a hard helmet on top of
that gun yeah when it's like a memorial
for somebody but for some reason there's
this little beanie that has significance
yeah yeah it's like one of the dwarves
from s white left their cap exactly from
ancient times okay
um the Fran cap is a soft conical cap
with the top pulled forward associated
with Antiquity with the inhabitants of
Fria a region of Central Anatolia in the
western provinces of the Roman Empire it
came to signify freedom and the pursuit
of Liberty perhaps through a confusion
with the pus the felt cap of manumitted
emancipated slaves of ancient Rome okay
so that's fine I just like that
backstory let's continue
we can go to the next oh I'm sorry can
you go back one yes um yeah so according
to the freaking cap is sometimes called
the liberty cap signifies freedom in
pursuit of Liberty we already said that
libertas along with the other Roman
goddesses have served as the inspiration
for many Modern Day symbols so this is
straight from a um Source on Statue of
Liberty of course including the Statue
of Liberty on Liberty Island in the USA
according the National Park Service the
statue's Roman robe oo so Roman robe the
liberty Statue of Liberty has a Roman
robe it is the main feature that inv
invokes libertas and the symbol of
Liberty from the statue derives its name
the fictional characters Colombia oh I
don't know these people but I don't
think that's really important they were
basically created um as seen as
embodiments of libertas national
embodiments of Liberty included in the
United Kingdom so they have other
statues here called Britannia in the
United Kingdom Liberty enlightening the
world is what its name is commonly known
as the Statue of Liberty in the USA and
Maryanne in France so they have other
ones set up in other places of the world
this is important right here I like this
because it says in 1793 during the
French Revolution the notra Dame de de
Paris cathedral was turned into a cult
of Reason wow Cult of reason that is
important yeah that's so important
because and for a Time Lady Liberty
replaced the Virgin Mary on several
altars what in the world oh my goodness
this is crazy if you know about this
historical
time this is when atheism came on the
scene in France heavily and what they
did was they took a prostitute they
named
her libertas okay or Lady Liberty and
they called
her um this Age of Reason basically the
cult of reason the Age of Reason has has
not come on the scene they paraded her
through the streets and they basically
dissed religion yeah I remember like
like I said I'm not a huge history buff
I don't know about all this stuff but I
have heard about this Age of Reason that
happened in France where they were like
stomping the Bible in the streets and
stuff and now even though we know that
the Virgin Mary is not really Mary at
all but is a false god this Age of
Reason has come in and replaced a
religious uh you know a Christian kind
of Icon yeah uh to prove that we are
what they're saying is true Liberty is
getting away from God yes Liber that is
Satan that's his agenda his yeah his
definition of freedom is
lawlessness uh what the do what thou
Wilt that's freedom but that's not true
Freedom according to the Bible God talks
about his law as being the law of
Liberty it's the law of love the very
thing that everyone Longs for in this
life is love and acceptance and all
these things and they say love is love
and all that but that's a counterfeit
true love is the four the first four
Commandments is how you love God the
last six is how you love your fellow man
and if we all just followed that we'd
live in a perfect world of Perfect
Harmony and peace and love so to add to
that usually when you have atheism and
it comes on the scene it replaces God in
all spiritual things with science yeah
logic and information and knowledge
science falsely so-call yes so that's
what reason that's the actual reason
they're speaking of just to give context
to that yeah um but that was a huge
moment in history for all of the world
because all of a sudden you have people
turning their backs on God completely
wow and this is what this
statue actually represents Cult of
reason they say yes yes so um that's
really all we need on that one so yes
I'm so glad someone mentioned Samir miss
here so good I'm really happy because
she was the first known you have Nimrod
I hope you guys know the backstory
that's again another reason why you need
to go watch the other videos we've done
called U who's the rain man because you
have Nimrod he's mentioned in the bible
he is um
Noah's son Ham
um who was kind of unfortunately the
perverted one in the Noah's Arc who was
um saved he had a son and his grandson
became Nimrod pretty much and Nimrod
married his mother and made her his wife
and uh mother I guess and so then he
died and if you know that story she
became they birthed bail worship
together as a couple and he ended up
dying cuz Shem um his great uncle again
killed him so Nimrod is died
um smear Miss is now on the scene who
still is
grieving her son hasband Nimrod wow and
and then all of her devotees are still
following all of what she dictates as
bail worship so a sun worship having
priests having um confessional having uh
Vestal virgins Vestal virgins having
which would be the nuns that's right we
are getting to that but I'm glad you
said that because let's just let's go
ahead and just say that because it's
true Vestal
virgins are nuns today they live in um
convents and abies but you will see um
if you do your history on Vestal virgins
their Chastity depended on they
basically dictated everything for the
Roman Empire their victory over War um
peace with their allies harvests um
games and victory in the games for the
athletes um everything basically
everything wow and if you
found something went bad I guess whether
it was war or peace or whatever you were
said to have lost your virginity if they
if they found you pregnant basically
they would starve you to death and bury
you in a hole alive with a very limited
amount of food and that was said to be a
merciful death because they're just
they're not really killing you they
would say you're just dying for lack of
food and that would killed the baby
inside of you as well so as of course
many Vestal virgins and nuns today have
done they are abused and raped and used
as a bride of Christ literally as a um a
sex
wow doll if you will for the priests how
do I know this well they have
documentaries they have um testimonies
on this from the nuns today oh yeah and
you'll see that this is correct because
even in ancient times and today you'll
find that there are Trails uh that's not
the right word tunnels from the convents
and the monasteries which Baby Bones in
them because people don't want to lose
their life when they've been found to be
abused be molested and then conceive and
then
be I guess having the punishment of that
yeah that they were going to lose their
life because they're said to have not
been a faithful bride of Christ so
anyway we've seen that today we see that
in Antiquity as well these all these
tunnels and Graves of cemeteries of
babies bones all along the way wow in
the tunnel leading from one place to
another um
so there you go that's the Vestal
virgins
um the The Flame by the way is right
here we're going to be getting to that
so it was
first um seen in samiramis being a God
you can see on her head are those Crown
uh the Rays of the sun on her crown and
there's seven of them just like the Lady
Liberty that's right and Lady Liberty
has the flame and on the BFF of it here
the statue of
the goat um in the middle you have not
really the you have the pentagram as I
guess if you want to say the the crown
of the Rays of the Sun but you have the
flame in the middle of his horns yeah
and that is important we're going to um
be focusing on that a little bit in just
a bit but these are where your mind can
go these were the this Trail I guess
that I'm showing you that my brain took
to get to where we're at um we can go to
the next slide and that caducus phus in
the middle there uh is you know exactly
what we see here as well and Sam Samaria
Sam samiramis samiramis um the the two
serpents wrapping around each other the
caducus logo there yes okay so here we
have in ancient times we have the very
image which the Statue of Liberty took
of the sun god
Helios um this is in Vi at the Museum uh
Natural History Museum it looks like but
you have all the elements again you have
the sun rays and the crown you have even
the the color of the skin being um what
is that color again the green there the
green copper um right that's a oxidized
metal there oh well that's not important
really but I but the robe and the arm
too exactly you have what appears to be
chains on the feet we look at that in a
minute we have the flame the torch in
the hand and this is Helios okay it's a
Sun God then we have from Statue of
Liberty
tour.com their definition of why the
torch and Crown is there it says her
torch was added to represent progress
giving the statue a more peaceful
appearance rather than invoking
violence um around her head the crown
seven rays form a Halo representing the
sun wow there it is the sun worship
again there you go and Liberty
enlightening the world this goes back to
exactly what they said with the cult of
reason and this progress Enlightenment
yes bringing Enlightenment to the world
with sun worship exactly so here we go
we can continue there then it became
this thing in the ancient world I
believe it was in Greece um we had
another statue resembling very similar
things called The Colossus of
roads and what does it say there the
Statue of Liberty website said that the
statue of was uh was a a remodeled
version of this yes it did so it was a
recycled image that's right it was it
was originally naked and boats passed in
between it just like you can see on the
left there and it had the flame even and
it had the um
Crown so but it's a man by the way if
you notice it's all men up to this point
yeah Lady Liberty looks very masculine
probably a t maybe yeah
okay so let's continue um here's exactly
again from their website Statue of
Liberty
tour.com all the Statue of Liberty is
undoubtedly bari's most famous work he
was very well known for another project
a statue that was never actually built
years before he began the Statue of
Liberty Bari was hired to design a
statue planned for the entrance the S Su
Suz canal in Egypt his research led him
to ancient giant Egyptian statues and
eventually to the classes of roads this
ancient bronze statue is over 100 feet
tall and considered one of the Seven
Wonders of the Ancient World the figure
was placed at the harbor entrance to the
Greek city of rhs showing the god of the
sun Helios carrying a light to guide
ships they're even saying it sound
familiar yeah so Statue of Liberty was
based off of Helios which is right here
on the left yes they're telling you MH
that Lady Liberty holding that Flame the
lightbearer with the seven sun rays on
her head uh and the the robe maybe
covering her male genitalia I don't know
but they're saying that Lady Liberty is
Helios the son God they're not even
hiding it yeah um I will add here the
very last sentence is um very
interesting it says ultimately this led
BART BART holdi to design what became an
early mockup for the Statue of Liberty
so he's giving where his inspiration
came from also inspired by Colossus it
says right there he created a robed
middle eastern woman wow now it's a
woman suddenly a peasant holding up a
fiery torch he called it Egypt carrying
the light to Asia Egypt so he's even
saying where it comes from it's from
Egypt their religious influence carried
carried carrying the light sorry to Asia
um so it's spreading throughout the
world he wanted it to be spread
throughout the world in
fact so um we cannot avoid the fact that
like I said that that torch is in
between the bamit um horns so now we're
going to go directly to the satanic
temple and see first a little
interesting note uh which they say it
says what is a satanic temple well it's
a group the group describes itself as
satanists secularists and advocates for
individual liberty liberty
okay this is exactly the deception which
Satan is using right for everyone to
have their own rights and Liberty to
choices quite honestly that they should
yes they should have free will but at
the same time to make choices and live a
life that is quite downright ungodly
right I mean the opening ceremony for
this statue opened with a gay kiss yes
why did they do that they unveiled at
the right at the unveiling they had two
guys kiss each other just to show you
that we are completely Sodom and gomor
we're going to do what we want to do and
we are disregarding God's laws yes and I
think it's important to read the next
sentence actually there because it says
we understand the satanic figure as a
symbol of man's inherent nature
representative of the Eternal Rebel
enlightened iniquity I'm sorry inquiry
and personal freedom rather than a than
a Supernatural deity of or being so he
was an enlightened one they believe yes
Satan Lucifer was Enlightenment yes okay
so now we truly get to where they're
saying this torch between the horns
comes from it says the torch of
knowledge is the middle horn it
glorifies the pursuit of knowledge we
put a high value on that it's really
Central to our beliefs in
general wow yeah the knowledge of Good
and Evil the tree of knowledge of Good
and Evil M God was Never Keeping
Knowledge from us he didn't want us to
know about evil but these people they
say look this is this is what we care
about most yes the knowledge that
Lucifer brings M and lastly they say um
the flame of intelligence shining
between his horns is the magic light of
the universal balance the image of the
Soul elevated above matter as the flame
whilst being tied to matter shines above
it wow so you can see how they're
upholding knowledge over Godly like God
at all yeah acknowledging God and
acknowledging his word and everything a
lot of these movies have these uh
Gnostic themes in them and it's making
me think of Transformers where the
trailer alone you can see how Gnostic it
is the the good guy the good Transformer
guy whatever his name is U Optimus Prime
is talking and he's he's talking about
this cube in space which we know that
there's the Heavenly cube is the New
Jerusalem out there in the heavens and
uh it's talking about that this Cube
created worlds and all the life in the
worlds all spark it sparked all life
yeah and then he says all sentient
beings deserve Freedom how do we get
that freedom destroy the cube destroy
the Creator to get Freedom this is this
is literally the words of Satan wants
you to believe that freedom comes from
lawlessness just think of a world
without laws think of a world without
order it would be pure chaos it' be why
not why can't I have your wife why can't
I take this from the store without
paying for it why can't I lie to your
face you know these are why can't I
murder you if it's do what you want
whatever feels good to you there are no
rules that's utter chaos and that's pain
and misery and and that's really what
we're experienced in this world today
because we decided to disobey God in the
beginning and Adam and Eve's firstborn
son became a murderer and that has just
perpetuated throughout the world today
to where I'm I don't want anything of
this world anymore I want Christ to come
him to set up his perfect Kingdom and us
to live forever and ever in eternity
where there's no more pain no more
sorrow No More Tears I long for that but
Satan has you
convinced that you don't want that in
fact that's that's hell to live in a
world like that would be you know to an
atheist they hate Christians why would
they ever want to live in a world with
with a bunch of Christians and and the
god that they hate so much but they've
been blinded by Satan into thinking that
God is taking away freedom and liberty
when he's the creator of freedom and
liberty no that's that's interesting but
those connections are definitely there
and here we
are um this painting by Sir Thomas
Lawrence
P it's oil on canvas it's actually
called Satan summoning his Legions now
just look at how the stance that he has
his face this really resembles the exact
images we've just seen and as I show
right there of Helios it's very similar
there you are um of libertas the the
crown of of the Rays of the sun are on
their heads likewise Statue of Liberty
you have there then they get to the set
face that's so Grim um that's on that
picture to the lady of liberty oh yeah
it's it's an identical face right and
now we're going to um look at this other
Statue just called Lucifer there where
he he kind of has all those things going
for him still he has the Grim face he's
he's got nakedness um The Robe covering
him but he has a few items in hand that
are unique he has a scepter that seems
broken and a a crown that has a few
broken um tops to it but he does have
certain amount of
uh what what what do we call that on on
top of the crown those little knobs
there's seven of them exactly just like
Lady Liberty I I noticed the broken
chain on his foot if you look at statue
of Li if you look down at her foot it is
she has a Broken Shackle broken chain on
her foot as well I don't think this is
just a coincidence that that Lady
Liberty is an exact mirror image of
Lucifer yeah in these artworks these
pieces of art right so next one actually
this will bring the
pieces
um together
here um so Helios just to to reiterate
that this is how he was depicted did in
ancient times very early
on um in what does that say there what
BC I can't read that fifth BC maybe so
he was shown all throughout history as
different things so basically he came
first is what I'm getting there um and
he's depicted pretty often with that uh
sun behind his head with all the Rays
and um libertas of course was the Roman
goddess of Liberty and personal freedom
her cult Rose to prominence around the
SE 2 Century bcee especially during the
Roman Republic so there we have it from
their
mouths
um oh actually let's let's read this
part real quick go to the very bottom
with me um the second paragraph from the
bottom says Helios was depicted as a
handsome usually beardless man clothed
in purple robes and crowned with The
Shining oral of the son his Sun Chariot
was drawn by four sometimes
winged
steeds um Helios was identified with
several other gods of fire and light
such
as heos I don't know if I said that
right hephestus I think is what the next
one says and light bringing
apolon oh AP right or Apollo
okay um so here we've zoomed up on that
picture for you with like he said those
prongs on the um Crown the scepter
that's broken the feet that are Shackled
they even have some pretty monstrous
looking uh Nails on those
feet and and it looks like an apple
that's been bitten out of along with the
top of that scepter so um that's where
the rest of it went so that should tell
you as we know from the Bible who you
know who was linked with this apple
right and will be Shackled In Chains and
and there you have it there's right
where the Statue of Liberty has the same
chains going on with the feet you can
see it there and there
mm okay
so this guy shows up like they said a
Soul Invictus he these all bear a lot of
the same resemblance to Soul Invictus
this is kind of important because I'll
just read the bottom there say soul en
IUS in ancient Rome Solen victus the
unconquerable son was a later Roman sun
god The Cult of Solen vicus was
popularized by the Roman emperor
aruan in uh 274
CE um why is that important some might
ask so
the where we get what we call the
Christian Movement of the day with
Constantine yeah he apparently had a
sign in the Clouds of a cross given to
him by the unconquerable
son that's true yeah he he saw a Red
Cross in the sky and he was so inspired
by it that he painted a red cross on the
shields of all his soldiers before they
went into battle and he proclaimed to
become a Christian right but in doing so
you know because formerly before that
they were killing Christians the Romans
were and so he basically changed that
and said you know what I I think it was
if you can't beat him join him type
thing maybe he really did see this
Vision in the sky maybe he really was
deceived by Satan I don't believe that
he was a true convert no um but he was
either deceived or completely made it up
and said look we we're not going to kill
Christians anymore we're going to let
you worship yeah and yep instead of on
the Sabbath you're to do it on Sunday
the venerable day of the Sun by law
there you go and if you're caught
judaizing if you're caught doing
anything that the Jews would do or
keeping the Sabbath you'll be killed but
all the shops will be closed on on the
venerable day of the Sun and you will
keep Sunday and you can go to church in
this temple with all these Idols in it
no that's not Mars and Venus and Mercury
that's actually Paul and Barnabas and
you know and and just this is where all
this started yeah this is where all the
imagery that you see in the Roman
Catholic Church all the Traditions all
the things that are still going on today
it all started with this uh who was
this well Constantine was one yeah
constan this yeah and so it's
like as I've heard other people say it's
baptized paganism yeah that is now
called Christianity yeah that's all it
was and that's where happened and that's
where Soul Invictus really came in plus
there's connections I I hate to admit it
but
um usually when you get to the titles of
the Pope he has one that's very similar
to the unconquerable
son um so he's calling himself almost
equivalent to the this God Soul Invictus
wow and so um yeah there's that
connection there's a lot of suns in the
Vatican too a lot of sun uh imagery
including all seeing eyes and all of
that too
mhm okay so just to close out what we
saw in the Olympics um I didn't know if
a lot of us have not caught on to this I
didn't until this year that the closing
ceremony has a hym to Apollo in it in
which we saw that one woman uh sing I
Did It My Way yeah um and so these songs
are Always sung in The Same Spirit of
freedom and liberty and the pursuit of
Liberty um to make your own choices
basically to put yourself up as a God in
in place of the real God well that song
my way was H Frank Sinatra song it was
one of the first songs that were
recognized as like the most satanic song
ever because it was all about
disregarding
anything any rules or anything I did it
my way I succeeded because I did it my
my way and even if bad things happen
it's okay because it was my way yeah and
uh just such a why would they pick that
song to sing at the end of the Olympics
it doesn't even make sense yeah and the
himym to Apollo when you look at what a
Himel is it's a religious song It's a
song of worship so while everyone's
gathering at this event from all around
the world and people are tuning in on
their TVs they're participating in a
worship to Apollo yeah at this Olympics
that's really all about Zeus worship I
mean M there it's crazy how Satan is
literally deceiving the world Revelation
says that the dragon who is Satan will
deceive the entire world and we see how
he's ens snared so many people with so
many different disguises and so many
different fun activities like the
Olympics or Christmas time or Easter or
whatever it is he's tricked Humanity
into worship shipping false gods which
are nothing more than demons or Satan
himself and he has literally deceived
the whole world like we are so close to
the end I believe that Jesus is coming
soon I believe that the dragon has
already deceived the world and many
different ways I'm thankful to see that
there are people that are waking up to
this stuff when we started this channel
almost three months ago I'm inspired by
all the comments I see from people
coming in saying like I've only been a
Christian for 4 years years and I'm I'm
noticing this about the holidays and my
family is you know almost disowning me
because I don't keep the holidays and
it's it's amazing to think that these
things have so much power in our lives
that if you don't keep this one day
you're basically disfellowship from your
family and ostracized yeah yeah like
You're Not Alone by the way we all have
family members at some point or one or
another that um
in I guess in reaction to our not
keeping these holidays and participating
in Olympics or watching them or whatever
it might be sports or something they
also don't uh usually it doesn't draw
people to you in that way if they are
about the world and so I hope that that
makes sense I'm just trying to say that
you are not alone we also have that hurt
in us that they shy away from us but you
can only be example you can only be kind
and loving to them and if they ever want
to talk you can be there for them yeah
um and it's you know we are A peculiar
people as God's people Jesus said it's
it's a narrow way it's a small door
there's a broad way out there that's
that's another one Broadway it's a broad
way to
destruction
and when you take a stand for God and
you say I'm going to keep God's
Commandments I'm going to keep the
Sabbath the fourth Commandment that
triggers a lot of Christians even and
you'll have Christians come against you
and say oh you don't got to keep that
it's interesting that the Ten
Commandments are in almost every Church
no matter what denomination you're part
of but they will fight against that
fourth Commandment because of tradition
the traditions of men and Jesus said
that he he was talking about the
Pharisees and he said they make void the
law of God by keeping their own
Traditions so if you keep God's
Commandments or you do anything that's
really biblical you
avoid Evil movies and games and all
these things the world is going
to uh ridicule you and it's it's really
their own conviction they can't admit
they don't want to believe that what
they're doing is wrong and if you say I
do this because I believe in God and I
believe the Bible and I and I'm
convicted by the Holy Spirit on this
that convicts them especially if they're
a believer because they're thinking no
that can't be true it must be your own
personal conviction or something they
don't want to admit that what they're
enjoying and loving like movies about
witchcraft like Harry Potter or whatever
are evil and they they have to return
with some kind of ridicule to make make
themselves feel comfortable and
contining and doing what they're doing
well especially if they Proclaim to be
Christian and you are actually showing
them like we are
um we're showing everyone how these are
linked with other gods God is a jealous
God he doesn't want you to participate
in other worship other gods and when you
bring that to
people's understanding
um a lot of them are not going to be
happy even Christians are not going to
be happy with you I forgot to mention
superheroes is another one so Satan's
ins snared us with Olympics holidays
superheroes
many other things that he's tricked us
into worshiping him and we'll be
covering some more of these things
I uh we already were looking into
covering some sports and how this um
reaches into that yeah and I think
you'll find that very interesting as
well um but yeah basically uh they built
a society a culture of bread and
circuses all around us to disguise the
worship of these other gods and also
distract us continually from actually
focusing on the things that matter which
are I guess reading the Bible praying
being with God even prioritizing your
relationship with God and also other
matters that are more important such as
uh I'll even put in there doing things
that are Godly Hobbies such as maybe
gardening or painting or yeah other
things that God gave us skills in or uh
to enjoy his nature
and him basically to pay attention to
his Small Voice and his character coming
through all this so did you have more
slides there I think there's one more um
just to to close it out oh my point here
is that it's in the Bible apolon or
um yeah aolon is in the
Bible
in it says revelation
91 yeah they had as king over them the
angel of the Abyss whose name is he oh
in Hebrew is abidon and in Greek apolon
in Hebrew the name abadon means place of
Destruction and the Greek title apolon
literally means the
Destroyer
so uh they even say down below let's
let's jump to the second to last
paragraph it says a badon or aoon is
often used as another name for Satan wow
wow well wow you know what this is
completely I'm I'm trying to figure out
uh the elites numerology stuff but the
fact that this comes from Revelation
911 I don't think it's any coincidence
or mistake that now we have that Date to
Remember yeah as uh something that I
don't believe happened like the media
said and it's all about Satan apolon who
is Satan yes and the extra point that I
had there written up there is um just to
show that it's in the Bible directly by
name but that name today and as it
became known in the Roman world uh the
the Yan I guess the y n on the back of
Apollo fell off and it just became known
as Apollo but this in mythology is known
as Zeus's son so there you have you have
Zeus and you got
Apollo so yeah they said that the
Olympics was about Zeus worship yeah and
you got Apollo because it's his son of
course we worship the father and the son
and that's what Satan's doing the same
thing with Zeus and Apollo right so the
very last slide um here is just closing
out this whole idea of the flame being
carried this is the very last picture in
that particular year that we were seeing
um the light bear bring the flame
forward
and it just emphasizes that these
are um almost 7,000 athletes from 205
countries that came down the river CNA I
think which came just hours after a
sabotage attack on the highspeed rail
networks
so that many people showed up wow oh we
all know that I'm sorry but I know it's
very obvious but the amount of people
that attend these things the amount of
people they hire to carry that flame
that we never knew about that I just
found out
tonight um to be ambassadors to to
nurture that flame all the way from
Olympia to its site where it's going to
be these um games are going to be held
and it says down below the opening
ceremony was the first in Olympic
history to be featured outside of the
main stadium so now they're taking that
flame outside of the sanctuary area even
though it it's it um originated there
they're taking it out of that area and
they're starting processions still with
the flame all the traditions and rituals
of Zeus worship just in a different
location sometimes
wow but we might have asked ourselves
sometimes who are these light Bears why
are they dressed weird like we just saw
in that picture um sometimes we don't
ask ourselves those questions enough and
we put together the whole picture now
for you yeah they are the light Bears
the torch the light bearers um this was
really interesting to me and it it's
really eye opening because it shows how
the dragon is out here deceiving the
whole world and and what we can do to
not be deceived you know that's what
Jesus said when the disciples were
asking what will be the sign of your
coming he said let no man deceive you uh
it was always about deception in general
and you know there might be people out
there that say why do you guys only just
focus on what Satan's doing you don't
ever talk about God we do and we're
going to we're going to have videos
about biblical topics and everything but
we have a passion about exposing Satan
we see the deceiver and we want to uh
show what God has shown us with everyone
else and we we have been ens snared by
these things in the past I used to be
obsessed with anime and movies and games
and music and I was never a big sports
fan but that's the thing Satan has a
tackle box full of bait for everyone I
used to be involved in witchcraft if
Satan's like look you think witchcraft
is dark and scary what about the new age
look it's all about light and love and
Colors oh you don't like that what about
um get obsessed with sports and that's
the thing it can be the most benign
thing if if Satan can keep you playing
Tetris all day long he wins he's got the
upper hand because he's keeping you
distracted he's keeping you from being
in the word of God In Prayer building a
relationship with God the word of God is
the sword of the spirit it's the only
weapon we have that can fight against a
powerful Angel which Satan is a powerful
Angel he's not some you know it bothers
me when Christians act like Satan's just
this puny little oh he ain't nothing he
is he's a powerful angel that deceived a
perfect Eve and a perfect Eden and we
are no smarter than that and so we have
to be on the lookout we have to not be
ignorant of Satan's devices and that's
why we're here on this channel doing
what we're doing we can only do this
with your support and we thank you guys
so much for being here we thank you for
the comments that are coming in we thank
you for those who are supporting we we
have tried to reach out to you uh some
of you we don't know personally but if
you have supported this ministry we are
thanking you from the depths of our
heart because we started this ministry
in faith stepping out in faith away from
a a steady paycheck and it's been
amazing to see God provide each week
each month um and we trust that he's
going to continue to do it and we doing
everything we know to do so we have uh
different
ways different ways you can support uh
cash there's vinmo there's zel we also
have some T-shirts if you want to check
out some of our cool merch um let me
pull that up real quick so you can see
it so we have some merch here on our
Teespring and you know the logo for our
channel is all about using your brain
it's cool to be smart it's cool to
analyze it's cool to study um the elites
of the world Satan he doesn't want us to
find the truth he doesn't want us
to uh use our brains he's hoping that
we'll just you know be mesmerized in the
whole bread and circus thing he's hoping
that we'll be easily controlled but we
have you know tote bags and shirts and
stickers and hoodies with our logo and
and different variations of the logo
like I call him the brain man we got the
brain man um on a hoodie here and you
can represent it showing that he has the
glasses on and he can see through all
the all the deceptions in the world that
it's a parody of they live and we're
going to continue putting out different
merch like that so that you guys can
have something cool to
wear um and to show your support and and
we get we get uh help that way too
financial support that way we love you
we're so glad you were here if you like
this please give it a thumbs up it
really helps it's a simple free way to
support this ministry the more you give
it a like the more YouTube will put that
on the algorithm share this with your
family and friends especially if you
know that they're really into sports or
the Olympics I hope this will be eye
opening I hope this will change their
life you know this is this is something
we want to do we want to plant seeds out
there so that somebody might have that
aha moment and just really start digging
diing deep about a lot of things in
their life and start making some serious
changes and to live a life that honors
God do you have any closing remarks I
just wanted to add that we have a
website it's called Candid truth.org
that's really where you will find the
shop to get
merchandise um we also on that website
have um a specific
donation um form connected to PayPal if
you want to use that over the other ways
you can donate um whichever one you want
we would yeah like he said we really
appreciate your help and support and we
hope that it'll continue so man thank
you so much thank you God bless and
we'll see you guys next time